so you think if you're in a like a
marriage and somebody has an affair that
there's a way
back from that absolutely it
well it really depends on the attachment
uh with both people the affairs that i
see i almost never see affairs
almost never see any extended kind of
affairs
outside of someone having an attachment
issue that usually is
women always ask why did he have an
affair usually because
he has the attachment issue and he is
too afraid to ask his wife for sex
so he spends 10 years trying to win
sex from her and eventually the marriage
gets soured because he's passive
aggressive and mean all the time to her
for not having sex with him so he then
goes out and finds someone to have sex
with
because he feels like the good person
now i have done so many good things for
you
you have never reciprocated i am the
good person this is also why people with
attachment issues tend to pick someone
who has a lot of
other issues because it's really easy to
read that person and say
look at all the nice things i can do for
you and take care of you and win your
love and win sex from you based on
all the things i take care of you for
that's where affairs tend to happen and
then coming back from those affairs
the most successful recoveries from
affairs that i see is when
we talk about attachment and one or both
partners says holy crap that's me
that's why all this happened and then
both partners do they do they ever say
holy crap that's you
sometimes yeah oh yeah if if one of them
doesn't have an attachment issue they
look at the other one and say
this is you and then the pieces start
clicking into place
and then they can say okay what you did
wasn't malicious you really believed
this was the only way for you to act
i don't want that and i'm now i hope you
don't realize
you realize you don't want that the way
that that relationship is fixed
is by the person who had the affair
coming back in and saying
these are all the behaviors from my
attachment issues these are the new
behaviors i'm going to do that will
show you i don't have those attachment
issues anymore all the open transactions
open sharing of needs everything i will
do all of that consistently
and by doing that that will prove that
you can trust me again
i have seen i've seen let's say wives um
in in affairs in marriages where there's
an affair i've seen the wife come in
and say i don't know that i can ever
trust you again and he fixes his
attachment issues
and within a couple of weeks she's
reporting more trust in him than she's
ever had in the marriage ever
even before the affair even at the
beginning of the marriage it was kind of
like well he's never done anything wrong
so i guess i'll trust him
to you are proving to me that you are
consistently
healthily attached to me and i know that
you will never have an affair because we
are so tight and so open
that we would see it coming 10 miles
away that's when marriages can get fixed
from affairs
and that's also how trust is rebuilt in
the marriage is when you have those
behaviors you have to actively rebuild
those
those that trust with healthy attachment
attachments everything
everything wow you're so full of
information
i don't think i've ever learned about
that that's so fascinating i've been
i think i was so ill for so long that i
kind of just i was like this is a
serious problem
like what's going on here's a serious
problem and all those psychological
techniques
and different ways of thinking are not
going to work which was true
but once i got rid of the like horrible
disorders
uh there's a lot there's a lot you can
do with like psychological techniques
and
changing the way you think and all these
natural things that so much
a lot of the medical community is not
aware of you know if you
get me going i'm one i'm one of the few
really people in the united states
that's talking about attachment
um dr robert glover is another one he's
a genius
his works are incredible um but as far
as
looking at attachments in adults very
rare i'm one of the few
people talking about it really like this
openly um
because our diagnostic statistics manual
specifies that
attachment disorders only happen in
childhood and that attachment disorders
must grow up into conduct disorders and
must grow up into personality disorders
so someone can have and that has to be
treated with drugs
personality personality disorders you
can't even a lot of times they say ah
you can't even really treat it yeah
you know we have we have things for
borderline personality disorder
dialectical behavior
therapy and stuff like that but um
it doesn't have to be that extreme you
can just have broken attachment
and very few people are talking about
that but if you get me on any
show me you know show me bipolar i tell
people if you have
in childhood and you are struggling with
attachment from
from birth or from three five whatever
it is
you're struggling with attachment and
you're struggling struggling struggling
and you really believe that if you show
people who you are they will reject you
and that they won't love you or they
won't take care of you they won't
protect you
whatever it might be then you believe
there's something wrong with you deep
down
you can become very closed off and say
i'm not going to share what i want or
you can become very aggressive and say i
have to
force you to give me what i want um you
can even switch some of those later on
but that's going to build anxiety
generalized anxiety disorder really
kicks in and starts taking off i've
treated
11 year olds with generalized anxiety
disorder full on disorders
that anxiety starts growing growing
growing until you're 12 13 14 15
and then your brain says so many bad
things keep happening and your brain
says just crank the anxiety up it's my
fault
i wasn't smart enough i didn't figure
out how to fix it i whatever it is just
crank the anxiety up and up and up and
up
by the time you hit 14 15 16 earlier
sometimes
your brain says bad things keep
happening to me and i'm worrying as much
as i can and i've given up so many
things just to keep worrying
there's just no hope and we develop
learned helplessness and depression
kicks in
um male depression is typically focused
on having a mission and being able to
accomplish that mission
female depression is typically focused
on being loved and being useful to the
people that you love just generalized um
generalizations there they'll get me in
trouble i'm sure with social media hi
everyone
um once that depression starts kicking
in
it grows and grows and grows and then
when bad things happen
your brain says there's no hope i can't
overcome this so we start developing
panic attacks
there's nothing i can do your limbic
system kicks on
the little brain when you're two years
old and your brain thinks people are
going to abandon you let's
ten thousand years ago our neolithic
brains ten thousand years ago
our brains are equipped to say if
someone abandons me when i'm two
bears will eat me in the forest and i
will starve to death so it connects
abandonment and rejection with death and
your limbic system clicks in every time
you're afraid you're going to be
abandoned
rejected whatever it might be so we have
these massive anxiety attacks
every time we feel like people are going
to leave us or hurt us or reject us
and with that depression kicked in we
believe there's nothing we can do about
it so we have these
life or death struggles um so attachment
and um attachment leads straight to
those panic attacks
eventually when you don't when your
panic attacks aren't doing anything for
you
nothing is working and bad things keep
happening
well borderline personality not
borderline um
that is one growth um blanking bipolar
bipolar disorder bipolar one and bipolar
two now the difference is um
manic and hypomanic it's how hard you go
um i always say bipolar one is
is type one is the hardest one go big or
go home um
bipolar kicks in now why does it kick in
well what does it do it gives you a
moment of rest
from all the worrying and all the
frustration
and all the terror about what people
will think of you and you have these
manic episodes or hypomanic
where you forget about all the
consequences your brain clicks off
the part that worries about consequences
and just says
i'm going to do what feels good
typically there's different features
there's paranoid and there's all kinds
of things
um but it clicks those pieces off and
says i'm just gonna
i'm gonna do what feels really good for
me and that can land you in the hospital
that can land you in jail that can land
you in all kinds of things because what
really feels good for you regardless of
consequences
sometimes it's not a great thing
especially if you've built up a lifetime
of repressing your needs and your
thoughts and your feelings
can really get some ugly places um but
but
that that's a feature above bipolar
people always think how do i stop
bipolar well what is it accomplishing
it's letting you feel what you really
feel and it's giving you
brief moments of happiness that you
otherwise would never feel
that's why when people start medicating
with people with bipolar they say
i kind of miss the episodes because
those were the only times i ever felt
happy
i hear that all the time when i work
with people who are medicated for
bipolar
um that's just one that's one night it's
one feature of it is it takes care of
[Music]
you
you